schulstart in corona zeiten in
mecklenburg vorpommern geht es wieder
los und nrw beschließt einen masken
pflicht im unterricht corona hotspot
offenbach nach einem anstieg der
infektionszahlen verschärft die
hessische stadt ihre schutzmaßnahmen
brücken eröffnung in genua zwei jahre
nach dem einsturz der moore an die
brücke mit 43 toten wird der neubau
eingeweiht
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am montag die vom
sport hat norbert lehmann dabei manche
wundern doch familie im norden sind die
sommerferien schon zuende genauer in
mecklenburg vorpommern und auf einigen
nordseeinseln
da gehen erstmals seit den chor ohne
beschränkungen im märz wieder mehr als
150000 junge menschen wie früher täglich
zum unterricht homeschooling ist nun
passé weitere länder folgen in den
kommenden tagen nach mecklenburg
vorpommern geht die schule am donnerstag
in hamburg
und nächste woche in gleich vier ländern
wieder los meist ist zum schutz vor
ansteckung vorgesehen schüler sollen in
festen gruppen bleiben und hygieneregeln
beachten
in einigen ländern gibt es eine masken
pflicht etwa auf fluren nordrhein
westfalen führt sie sogar im unterricht
ein nur grundschüler sind ausgenommen
alain caparros sie sind die ersten
schulstart in mecklenburg vorpommern
zumindest im unterricht ohne abstand und
maske wie hier am innerstädtischen
gymnasium rostock
im alltag kommt auch wenn wir viele
sachen beachten müssen ich finde das
schon ein bisschen schwer alle auf
einmal eine schule zu lassen ich will zu
machen das teil unterricht ist immer
zwei jahrgänge bilden eine gruppe die
keinen kontakt zu anderen gruppen haben
soll
für jede gruppe separate eingänge
getrennte wege
dass das gut geht hoffen eltern und
schüler
wir gucken jetzt jeden tag und die
presse sie zahlen steigen
von daher kann ich auch als
elternratsvorsitzender nur das
unterstützen dass keine masken pflicht
im schulgebäude haben keine masken
pflicht also im unterricht aber auf den
gängen an dieser schule gilt diese regel
auch wenn sie landesweit bislang nicht
verpflichtend ist noch nicht die
landesregierung prüft eine verschärfung
ihrer auflagen
wir haben die klare empfehlung die
masken pflicht einzuführen
in den bereichen des schulgeländes in
dem in den gängen nicht in den
klassenräumen und das ist die der rat
bei uns in mecklenburg vorpommern
anders als der nordosten will nordrhein
westfalen als erstes bundesland eine
masken pflicht auch während des
unterrichts in weiterführenden schulen
einführen
lehrer müssen nicht so die beschlüsse
sie werden vorerst bis zum 31
august 2020 befristet und bieten so die
gelegenheit die entwicklung des
infektionsgeschehen es insbesondere
während und nach der ferien bedingten
rückreisewelle sorgfältig zu beachten
und dann neu zu bewerten
der alltag in diesem corona schuljahr
wird zu einer herausforderung für alle
beteiligten
ja so sieht wohl der neue schulalltag
aus dauerte ferber mund nasenschutz
sogar im unterricht warum rechnung
gerade nordrhein westfalen damit vor die
schulministerin begründet ist damit das
ist das erste bevölkerungsreiche
bundesland ist das wieder zum unterricht
zurückkehrt da müsse man besonders
achtsam sein und wir haben es gehört
auch weg der rückreise weil er sei
besondere vorsicht geboten
man muss vielleicht auch sehen dass die
kommunikation der landesregierung vor
den ferien gerade im schulbereich als
besonders chaotisch vielfach kritisiert
wurde vielleicht möchte man dem
mit den strengen regeln begegnen
unterricht mit maske wie soll das
eigentlich im schulalltag funktionieren
ja das fragen sich viele die landes
schülerkonferenz kritisiert dass
angesichts der hohen temperaturen die
der nächste bekommen sollen das gar
nicht zumutbar sein die maske den ganzen
schultag zu tragen und der verband
bildung und erziehung kritisiert dass
gerade das zwischenmenschliche im
unterricht ja wichtig sei die mimik eben
die komme zu kurz mit der maske aber man
sagt auch das ist eben viel besser sei
gemeinsam in der schule lernen zu können
als das eben nicht zu können und das
auch das sprechen mit der maske eine
gewöhnungssache sei und letztlich hat
die landesregierung das ganze ja erst
mal als eine art versucht mit befristung
angelegt ende august dann will man
weiter sehen
vielen dank dort bewerber war das
schulstart in der pandemie wie die
einzelnen bundesländer damit umgehen und
wo was gilt in sachen regelunterricht
abstand und maske all das finden sie
online in unserer zdf heute etwas die
korona einschränkungen bei schulkindern
auslösen haben mediziner der leipziger
uniklinik erforscht dabei ging es ihnen
vor allem um die sozialen und die
seelischen folgen wenn schulen
geschlossen werden
und die sind umso gravierender je
geringer bildung und einkommen des
elternhauses sind steffen moritz hat
sich die ergebnisse angesehen
900 kinder und jugendliche in
grundschulen und gymnasien wurden
befragt zu beginn der schulschließungen
und vier wochen danach
erstaunlich für die wissenschaftler war
welche zukunftssorgen die schüler und
schülerinnen haben
so sorgen sich die meisten kinder mehr
um ihre familien als um sich selbst 20
prozent glauben dass es nie wieder so
wird wie vor cupid 19 und 75 prozent
aller kinder wünschen sich einfach nur
dass sie wieder normal zur schule gehen
können
allgemein beklagen die schülerinnen und
schüler dass ihnen der kontakt zu
gleichaltrigen fehlt es keinerlei
tagesstrukturen mehr gibt und einen
verlust an lebensqualität
familiären verhältnisse der kinder
spielten bei der befragung eine große
rolle
familien die in beengten verhältnissen
leben ihren kindern keine bildung
weitergeben können
und das ist das ergebnis unserer studie
leiden extrem unter schulschließungen in
setzen sollen aufgrund der sehr
niedrigen infektionszahlen die schulen
nach den sommerferien wieder regulär und
ohne masken pflicht und abstandsregeln
öffnen wenig abstand keine masken die
großdemo in berlin am wochenende gegen
die korona maßnahmen und steigende
infektionszahlen haben eine breite
diskussion ausgelöst
bundespräsident steinmeier hat jetzt zu
mehr vorsicht aufgerufen
die verantwortungslosigkeit einiger
weniger ist ein risiko für uns alle wenn
wir jetzt nicht besonders vorsichtig
sind dann gefährden wir die gesundheit
viele und wir gefährden darüber hinaus
die erholung unserer gesellschaft
unserer wirtschaft unseres kulturlebens
und jetzt zu den aktuellen corona zahlen
die neue infektion in deutschland
bleiben auf einem vergleichsweise hohen
niveau
im schnitt der letzten sieben tage haben
sich täglich 650 menschen neu angesteckt
am wochenende lag der schnitt bei 200
bei 680 und es gibt wieder einen lokalen
corona ausbruch diesmal in hessen mit
offenbach hat es jetzt aktuell auch die
bundesweit erste größere stadt erwischt
in den letzten 7 tagen gab es dort 36
neue infektionen pro 100000 einwohner
offenbar haben viele das krone virus aus
dem urlaub im ausland eingeschleppt und
das hat jetzt konsequenzen wie isabel de
la vega berichtet dichtes gedränge in
der offenbacher innenstadt während die
fallzahlen steigen
teilnehmer einer busreise in die
niederlande und rückkehrende urlauber
aus risikogebieten
konnten als hauptquelle identifiziert
werden von diesen 46 personen damit sie
mal einordnen können was ich gerade
gesagt habe gehen also 15 erkrankte auch
die busreise zurück und 19 erkrankte
sind solche reiserückkehrer
es gibt jetzt neue maßnahmen für
offenbach darunter sofortige pflicht
tests für rückkehrer aus risikogebieten
neue abstandsregeln für sport und
veranstaltungen und ein verbot von
grillen oder picknicken maßnahmen sind
das eine das andere die zunehmende
sorglosigkeit vieler offenbacher ich
glaube ich gesehen ihn bringen können
ich habe zum beispiel einer tankstelle
das irgendwie egal ob die halt masken
haben oder nicht liegt auch daran dass
jugendlichen also wirklich beratungs
starten hier in offenbach maske bringt
so oder so nichts bei der man nach
müssen diejenigen tragen die krank sind
eine fehlinformation corona spaltet
viele offenbacher sind zu sorglos andere
können sich keinen zweiten lockdown
leisten
wir sind ja in der innenstadt und wir
haben eine sehr hohe miete die wir
zahlen müssen um drei monate das sammelt
sich bloß noch die mitarbeiter irgendwie
haben wir es uns noch durch gekämpft
aber jetzt sollte nochmal dies der fall
sein würde das für uns eine
existenzbedrohung
die stadt versucht nun noch strengere
einschränkungen zu verhindern
ins ausland nach australien da erlebt
vor allem die millionen metropole
melbourne eine heftige zweite virus
welle die fallzahlen in der stadt und
dem bundesstaat victoria steigen
deutlich 429 neuinfektionen allein dort
von gestern auf heute die behörden
reagieren mit drastischen neuen
einschränkungen nachts gilt eine
ausgangssperre
und jetzt müssen auch die allermeisten
geschäfte wieder dichtmachen normen
odenthal
jetzt ist fast alles dicht fabriken
geschäfte schulen nichts fährt mehr
nichts geht mehr
denn australiens zweitgrößte metropole
hat das größte problem die meisten
neuinfektionen die meisten toten
melbourne wird zur geisterstadt
spätestens wenn es dunkel wird
es ist eine brutale zeit und die
nachrichten sind herzzerreißend
unvorstellbar dass wir in unserem land
mal eine nächtliche ausgangssperre
verhängen müssen für eine metropole wie
melbourne aber in dieser pandemie ist
nichts mehr unvorstellbar corona schien
besiegt es war eine illusion die zweite
welle der zweite lockdown der jetzt noch
einmal verschärft wird denn nach drei
wochen breitet sich das virus immer noch
aus auch weil sich infizierte nicht an
die quarantäne halten
befolgen sie die regeln es gibt keine
alternative
lassen sie sich testen auch beim
mildesten symptomen und bleiben sie zu
hause wenn sie auf ein testergebnis
warten oder bereits mit dem virus
infiziert sind strikte kontrollen harte
strafen aber auch hilfe wer finanziell
nicht abgesichert ist wenn der lohn in
14 tagen quarantäne wegbricht bekommt
1500 dollar knapp 1000 euro vom staat
das soll den wirtschaftlichen druck
nehmen wer allerdings versucht das geld
beim einkaufen los zu werden braucht
geduld und gute nerven noch weitere
sechs wochen strengster lockdown liegen
vor meldung familie und weggefährten
haben abschied vom verstorbenen früheren
spd vorsitzenden hans jochen vogel
genommen an der trauerfeier in münchen
nahm auch bundespräsident steinmeier
spd chef walter borjans würdigte vogel
als einen der ganz großen der
sozialdemokratie dessen leben im dienst
der menschen gestanden habe vogel war am
26 juli im alter von 94 jahren gestorben
bei einem angriff auf ein gefängnis im
osten afghanistans sind mindestens 29
menschen getötet worden
zu der attacke bekannte sich die terror
miliz es die angreifer zündeten eine
autobombe und stürmten daraufhin die
haftanstalt dort sitzen vor allem
kämpfer des und der taliban ein
wie viele der rund 1700 häftlinge
fliehen konnten ist unklar
1000 seine angaben der behörden wieder
gefasst
heute wird in der norditalienischen
hafenstadt genua eine neue brücke
eingeweiht
dort wo vor ziemlich genau zwei jahren
die morandi brücke einstürzte ein rund
200 meter lange abschnitt brach aus der
konstruktion heraus und stürzte 40 meter
in die tiefe autos und lastwagen fielen
auf die häuser darunter 43 menschen
starben
wartungsmängel werden als grund vermutet
heute nun die einweihung der neuen
brücke die konstruktion aus stahl und
beton steht auf 18 pfeilern und ist mehr
als einen kilometer lang
der verkehr wird schon ab mittwoch
wieder rollen annette hilsenbeck
berichtet kurz vor der einweihung der
neuen brücke in rekordzeit von zwölf
monaten wurde sie gebaut dann viele
arbeitskräfte und sondergesetz nach zwei
jahren verkehrschaos unter dem auch der
große hafen die wirtschaft wird atmet
man auch in genua eine brücke wieder
aufzubauen heißt da aufschwung für die
wirtschaft der gesamten stadt
es ist ein wiedergeburt ein neuanfang
für die stadt eine schöne sache für uns
alle doch viele können nicht vergessen
warum die brücke gebaut wurde
patricia bellotto hatte die trümmer der
moore an die brücke das grauen direkt
vor ihren augen wenn sie auf ihren
balkon trat das neue bauwerk sieht sie
mit gemischten gefühlen
ich sehe natürlich ein wichtiges werk
von vielen arbeitern erbaut
das sehe ich mit den augen aber im
herzen fühle ich die andere brücke die
menschen die mit ihren die tiefe
stürzten
blumen und bilder für die opfer ihre
angehörigen wollten nicht teilnehmen an
der feier
sie fürchten die rückkehr zur normalität
nimmt auch den druck die schuldigen für
das unglück zu suchen
die ermittlungen laufen unter anderem
gegen den autobahnbetreiber autostrada
per l'italia leider wurden viele
kontrollen nicht gemacht wie die regeln
vorschreiben
sie haben effektiv nicht stattgefunden
und es gab ein problem mit der
instandhaltung in genua hoffen sie heute
abend der von der neuen san giorgio
brücke ein impuls ausgeht ein neuanfang
für ganz italien in diesen minuten wird
die brücke feierlich eröffnet und
annette hilsenbeck ist für uns dabei
hätte welche bedeutung hat dieser tag
für die italiener
für italien ist es besonders wichtig
dass jetzt mal gute nachrichten aus dem
land kommen
die brücke wurde ja in kürzester zeit
gebaut
unter einsatz
[Musik]
rechtlich ist damit liegt das land
besonders stolz und es braucht das auch
um das nationale trauma zu überwinden
dass der brücken sturz verursacht hatte
und ihm gerade in der korona krise die
italien besonders traf hat die brücke
eben auch einen hohen symbolwert es
heißt dass man ihn auch in der truck
nach einer tragödie den wiederaufbau
fahren kann
vielen dank annette nach italien nach
genua
willkommen zurück auf planet erde und
danke fürs fliegen mit spacex klingt
fast schon wie ein normaler
passagierflug dabei haben die
astronauten die so vom kontrollzentrum
begrüßt wurden geschichte geschrieben
sie landeten sicher im golf von mexiko
mit der raumkapsel eines
privatunternehmens es war die erste
wasserlandung einer bemannten us kapsel
seit 45 jahren die astronauten waren
zuvor zwei monate auf der
internationalen raumstation und jetzt
noch eine meldung aus spanien der
frühere könig juan carlos will sein land
dauerhaft verlassen
das teilte der palast in madrid mit
gegen den monarchen wird wegen eines
korruptionsskandals ermittelt es geht um
mögliche millionenzahlungen aus saudi
arabien
juan carlos hatte 2014 nach 39 jahren
auf dem thron zugunsten seines sohnes
philippe abgedankt wohin der ex könig
jetzt zieht ist noch nicht bekannt ja
und nun zu diesen arbeiten da wurde
heute in hoffenheim ein neuer trainer
vorgestellt und zwar einer mit großen
namen
der name hoeneß sebastian hoeneß sohn
von dieter und neffe von uli hoeneß sein
erstes engagement in der ersten liga
eine durchaus gewagte entscheidung für
beide seiten für den neuen tsg-coach und
für den verein
die chemie stimmt zwischen den beiden
der neue sebastian hoeneß und
hoffenheims sportchef alexander rosen
sicherlich ein mosaiksteinchen das zur
vertragsunterzeichnung geführt hat das
ist denke ich ein mutiger schritt von
von beiden seiten der dann aber auch
mit überzeugung auch aus den gesprächen
gelebt wurde sebastian hoeneß 38 jahre
alt einer der talentiertesten nachwuchs
trainer
zuletzt führte er die zweite mannschaft
des fc bayern zur meisterschaft in der
dritten liga nun also die große
fußball-bühne hoffenheim ein erstes
kennenlernen zwischen trainer und
mannschaft gab es bereits gestern vor
dem schlösschen unter ausschluss der
öffentlichkeit und vom neffen jetzt zum
onkel uli hoeneß der hat mal wieder
gegen seinen ärgsten liga-konkurrenten
gepoltert der ex bayern präsident
kritisiert dortmund transferpolitik mit
scharfen worten die reaktion von bvb
manager zorc die folgte prompt das erste
team training heute vom bvb ein
tummelplatz von top talenten wie dem
15-jährigen yussuf am bug oder dem 17
jährigen neuzugang youtube bellingham
dazu meldet sich ein alter kontrahent
die man auch verbal er im ruhestand
wenig bayern ehren präsident uli hoeneß
wie soll ein spieler die dna eines
vereins aufsaugen wenn er das gefühl hat
ein verkaufsobjekt zu sein
fußball talente sichten entwickeln und
teuer verkaufen laut hoeneß grund für
die mangelnde schlagkraft in den
entscheidenden momenten bvb
sportdirektor michael zorc stärker
zurück wenn man jedes jahr 250 millionen
euro mehr in der tasche hat lässt es
sich mit vollen hosen gut stinken
aber so ist es derzeit jeden sanchez zum
beispiel geht der bvb stallgeruch schon
langsam abhanden
die premier league ruft kaya meister und
vizemeister kommen so langsam wieder auf
betriebstemperatur drastischen worten
auf betriebstemperatur kommt auch der
august ab mitte der woche da wird es
nämlich heiß heute heißt es aber erstmal
achtung für südbayern
da wird entlang der alpen vor unwettern
und dauerregen bis morgen nachmittag
gewarnt dazu gleich mehr von gunther
tiersch das war es von uns schön dass
sie dabei waren
marietta slomka erwartet sie um 314 zum
heute-journal und wir sind morgen abend
wieder um sieben zur stelle
bis dahin machen sie es gut
[Musik]
unglaubliche zuschauer dauerregen an den
alpen ist jetzt unser thema duffys
derzeit etwas kühlere luft von
nordwesten und trifft auf die alpen
dort liegt die schwül heiße luft vom
mittelmeer ein riesiges regengebiet ist
entstanden und es regnet die ganze nacht
den ganzen vormittag erst morgen
nachmittag lässt der regen mehr und mehr
nach also intensiv der regen in den
kommenden stunden südlich des mains bis
zum erzgebirge und vor allen dingen sehr
intensiv südlich der donau in der
zweiten nachthälfte nach norden hin und
westen hin bleibt es allerdings klar
oder locker bewölkt es wird dann am
morgen ein freundlicher tag in
norddeutschland sonne wolken und diese
wollten zu den brandenburg sachsen etwas
dichter am erzgebirge kann es anfangs
hier und da noch etwas regen später
lockert auf und am nachmittag gibt es
vielleicht doch im westerwald mal ein
regenschauer aber südlich des mains und
vor allem südlich der donau regnet erst
einmal am vormittag weiter
nachmittags dann nur noch im
südöstlichen bayern es locker dann von
westen auf die sonne kann hier und da
mal raus kommt ja frisch ist im
dauerregen da sind es nur 12 bis 19 grad
20 an den küsten und sonst 22 bis 25
grad aber es wird ja wärmer es wird heiß
in den nächsten tagen und sonnig freitag
26 bis 35 grad und auch an den küsten
haben wir die hitze ich wünschen noch
einen schönen abend und machen sie's gut